last week I told you that we had a
really really great thing going on the
progressive musical artist named deep
glass and their self-titled album deep
glass sponsored 20 half-price
memberships for david pakman show
viewers and listeners so the way it
worked is deep glass has already paid
half of 20 yearly memberships and normal
yearly membership cost $60 they've
already paid $30 for 20 people so we had
20 of these half price memberships
available for whoever wanted them on a
first-come first-serve basis 13 of those
memberships have been spoken for already
and I have 7 left so this is this is a
really cool thing and we want to try to
support other progressive endeavors deep
glass is a progressive musical act and
you can check out the album on iTunes as
well as uncie d baby calm so number one
if you are interested in a membership
and all of the great perks that come
with it the bonus show the commercial
free audio feed the commercial free
video feed all of that great stuff but
the $60 a year price tag was a bit high
for you you can now take advantage of
getting a membership at half price $30 I
have seven of those left email me
through the website david pakman.com
click on contact us and say hey i want
one of those deep glass memberships i
expect the last may be another 24 hours
or just a little bit more also please
check out the album as well deep glass
is the artist and album cdbaby.com and
itunes and lastly for every album sold
if you want to buy the album for every
album sold until the memberships run out
deep glass will donate $3 to the
Institute for Women's policy research so
very exciting stuff I want everybody to
support the band because they are
supporting us and and it's all we all
want to help each other to the extent
that we can 7 half-price memberships
left email me if you want them check out
deep glass on iTunes and cdbaby.com